okay let's roll here with c4 maybe we'll
enter a similar position with the rules
reversed and they forgot to actually
just keep flipping that board when I go
over things so all right well this is
different let's get the knight out
and if Knight here isn't played right
away okay now we're having a Sicilian
reverse Sicilian will f5 be played
before Knight f6 we're gonna see about
that meantime Bishop g2 and okay let's
go forward with that and let's go
forward with more development I'm
retaining these the options with these
guys
it's castle and wow what else
rook be one with the early b4 b5 I don't
know about the knight move let's do this
there is some possibilities that the
rooks can be subjected to the rook on a1
can be subjected to tactics along this
diagonal so there's two reasons to want
to go with the rook b1 move instead of
let's say a three both support before
but this one stays out of trouble it
stays off of this diagonal now what I'm
gonna do this if the knight place here
I'm gonna consider avoiding the exchange
playing to d2 seeing how that I have a
slight space advantage well actually I
don't know do I really have a space
advantage on the Queen side I do this
pawn is far further advanced than my own
pond I'm a king side play Knight here at
any moment
hit that bishop and I'm gonna do this
actually is the Queen gonna play to d7
Queen d7 Knight to g5 and I am
officially picking up the bishop pair
now when g5 Bishop here g4 the very
valuable light square bishop the pawns
are on dark squares right here and the
bishop is complementing those pawns
quite well what else okay I could get
that Bishop whenever I want
I'm viewing this position by the way is
is one similar to that of having my
opponent's piece in a pin almost like my
knight it's usually the case that a
bishop would pin a knight to a king but
right now it's like this Bishop can't
move anyhow it's kind of in a pin in an
in a weird way right here
I pin peas can't move this bishop really
just doesn't even have any moves I could
take him any second should I be taking
him now no I don't see a reason to let's
move forward get my rook involved maybe
on the B file if this d5 move is gonna
be played it's not without it's not
without allowing a two-to-one majority
in the center and if my opponent doesn't
want to have to deal with the two-to-one
majority in the center c6 is going to be
played but if it's played my rook comes
to life well now that I was forced into
doing it now I'm gonna do it
if pawn takes and this file opens up now
this is a bit more weak actually these
last two pawn moves the one that kicked
my knight the one that attacked my
knight and the one that captured in this
direction both weakened to this g6
square so I'm wondering how can i maybe
get at that pawn bishop here a queen
maybe here the knight is supporting it
this file is half opened maybe Queen B 3
being opposite the King is not a bad
idea
and actually I like that idea so I'm
gonna go with that Queen B 3 a
developing move was one of the first
ones I was looking at had many moves I
could be making I'm still looking to
complete my development my opponent is
fully developed rooks connected I am NOT
my bishops still needing to move and if
this pawn presses forward this becomes a
much more appealing diagonal because it
could see the knight it's it's pinning
the knight to the rook the King is
shifting over getting off of that file
understandable I think this is a good
spot for my bishop even though it seems
like it's biting on a rock right now
this pawn can always be or this pawn
right here on d6 can always be
undermined with b6 and if my opponent
prevents me from doing b6 by playing b6
then that means my bishop can control
this square
and I can maybe be getting to the
seventh rank and putting pressure on
black that much easier now this night
what is it looking to do what's the
threat where would it like to go next
it's like it wants to go to this square
so I'm going to take that into account
and bump my pawn up a single square
that's probably the first question by
default that I ask myself when I'm
playing the game what is the threat what
is it my opponent is looking to do where
would that piece that they just moved
why would it like to go next
okay looking to double on the F file
interesting I think I should be pushing
right now pawn push pawn push pawn push
takes takes I think I want this position
to just open up can I make that work
okay okay okay there's gonna be doubled
rooks is there gonna be a sacrifice on
this Square at some point maybe I don't
want to push here just chase the knight
to a good square actually I'm gonna come
back here with my bishop and I'm gonna
look to get over here quickly this rook
can't go here so easily because I am on
this pawn as soon as that pawn moves
though I have this square available
maybe getting a knight there would be
good right A to B for c6 that really
does need to be calculated because I am
going backwards and this is not a closed
position so if I'm looking into moves
that are like that that are maybe a bit
long-winded maneuvering type of ideas
kind of have to weigh that is it worth
the time invested are you gonna be able
to accomplish a whole lot if you get
that in things of that nature are good
ones to be considering my rook isn't
doing anything let's get it doing
something on a I'm looking to converge
on this pond
there is no pond push the pond the pond
pushes are under control I am fearful of
this the Knights converging on this
square actually so we got this knight
ready to play here
interesting idea how about I stop that
these are counterparts the Knights that
were on c3 and f6 we're both fighting
over the same center squares and what
you'll find very often is that one one
of them moves the other one will that
your opponent's other Knight will like
to move right away so he just gave up
control this square I can actually
occupy it and defend against a follow up
square the knight wants to go too so now
that that knight is out of here these
pawns are broken up a bit I have this
square available but I'm liking this one
pig on the 7th hitting a lot of stuff a
lot of pieces maybe cutting off the king
the King does not have a good home I
think I just get this guy over here and
everything is gonna be okay I want to
get off one pair of rooks ok now we're
having that so let me do this I'm
looking for Queen B - I want to target
this pawn if this pawn is hit I could
defend like that Queen B 2 also defends
f2 and what next pawn push I think this
is the move that that ends up breaking
down black right now exploiting a pin
piling up on the pinned pawn and how to
recapture I'm gonna do this I know the
panca just take now since its defended
why'd I do that
there's no time I should have just taken
while I had the opportunity now I'm
gonna take the Knights gonna play here
though I'm gonna end up having to back
up
okay and I probably have to switch gears
here let's come over in this direction
it's the f6 square that I'm finding more
appealing right now
rook right here and if it's captured I
repair my pawn structure and I get my
bishop back to this e4 square I'm
looking to target g6 now pawn push with
g6 coming under fire okay this is
crumbling now no time no time no time no
time good game
let's back up let's see about this okay
okay I wonder if you could consider
instead of the night move sneaking in f5
and only then Knight f6 look into that
move f5 and then Knight f6 because then
you have possibilities of f4 going for a
King side attack is something you should
be looking into right now you have app
on your epon is further advanced than my
own you're maybe ready to kick my night
away at some point you're ready to maybe
open up the F file if you have your pawn
on f5 to consider this f5 and then
Knight f6 big difference I have more to
be concerned about you castle and
there's even pawn sacks with like Knight
here and then an another I know that
there's just a ton a lot more
possibilities if you have that in before
your knight comes to f6 so consider that
what else yeah also before you bump the
Queen up consider h6 a good move if you
actually sometimes you would even want
to play it before your Bishop plays here
so you could even consider it right now
two purposes stop the knight here and
looking a bit more long-term this is
often a better flight Square for the
King than the g7 Square this Bishop is
wanting to just hang out on that square
your king is going to want to have maybe
a different square available should I
get a rough back here one day all right
so h6 is another one to consider you
preserve your bishop pair right now I
end up getting it and I don't know if
you have successful pawn breaks here I
have the potential pawn breaks under
control if you're ever doing this I can
maybe go in for two rooks versus queen
situation I think I have coordination to
go in for that imbalance and
I think it's trouble I don't know I'm
I'm failing to see a good plan for black
so I think it's coming back to me
getting in this Knight takes Bishop
exchange I don't know if the resulting
pawn structure is enough for you right
here you get something in return okay
half open F file but can you really put
it to use a good question to ask I don't
know if that there's a great answer to
it I don't know if there is enough
compensation on that F file so okay so I
don't know if you were struggling to
find a plan maybe that's the reason why
maybe that's the the quick diagnosis
right here so you could me now you know
how you could be stopping that preserve
that bishops position before you play
here recognize its purpose guard g5
flight square as well and then run
forward with this and then this and then
I'm having to maybe do a ch3 King h2 in
response some food for thought